it's a full-blown disaster at our
southern border courtesy of joe biden
we're learning today that over 100
illegal immigrants infected with covid
were released by border patrol and
they're free to travel across the
country
keep in mind if an american citizen gets
covid they have to quarantine
and if you're flying into america from a
foreign country
you have to show a negative covid test
but those same rules don't apply
and there's even more a new report says
the department of homeland security is
projecting
there will be 117 000 unaccompanied
child migrants
crossing the border this year that
breaks all records
nearly a 50 percent increase from the
all-time record and
much higher than last year the report
also warning there's not enough
resources to handle that surge
everybody can clearly see this as a
crisis
well unless you work at the white house
at what point does it become a crisis
well i would say i i don't think we need
to meet your bar
of what we need to call it we are
approaching this humanely
and we are approaching this in a way
where we will keep the children safe did
you receive a briefing about the border
today
uh yes i did what did you learn
a lot is there a crisis
[Applause]
[Music]
all right gut felt i think they want
this to happen they invited this surge
and then it's easier to smuggle a child
across the border they bring back chain
migration
you grant animosity or asylum to a child
and that whole family gets to come up
and become american citizens now and
that's what they want they vote democrat
and there you go
did he say god willing like after that
like everything's gonna work i mean
he doesn't inspire confidence when
that's the last thing he said i think
that's what he said right
god willing you know that's like your
doctor when he's leaving yeah is
everything okay
god willing you know it's like thanks
pal 117
000 child migrants unaccompanied
by adults so i i asked this last week
what happened to their loving parents
since november
when trump was accused of ripping
children
from their parents now it's like i'm
beginning to think
we were lied to about that that there
weren't parents
that it was always like this you know my
wife was gone for a couple months she
came home and found out all the plants
were dead
and in science we call this cause and
effect
because i didn't water the plants and
they all died and so what you're seeing
on the border is the fastest clearest
refutation
of disastrous liberal policy it's
because it's cause and effect
you remove friction a barrier combined
with a message
that tells everybody it's okay to come
you get 117
000 uh unaccompanied uh child
migrants so if you want to follow the
science that's science it's cause and
effect you eat every day at cinnabon
you're gonna get fat
why is this a disaster for the democrats
because it destroys any trust people
have
in your abilities to solve any problems
your feel-good
objectives result in impossible
logistical challenge
you can't take care of 117 000
unaccompanied
child migrants the democrats have these
adolescent child-like goals
but they have no process because they
have no parents
in the party to solve the problem
juan if if biden really doesn't want
this migrant surge
why isn't he doing everything he can to
keep the
migrants in mexico or in central america
i think he is jesse i think that this is
a spike then why do you get rid of it
did that
i believe i believe most of those
policies are still in effect
and i think that they you know when you
look at the policies the united states
has had
uh and i go across various
administrations
we have seen these spikes they come they
go springtime all the rest and
we just don't have a consistent strategy
to deal
with high tide low tide and especially
uh with unaccompanied miners given our
amnesty position but you know the way we
started talking about a hundred kids
100 plus kids who have coronavirus you
know
we have 70 000 americans with
coronavirus right so i mean why are we
trying to pick on those kids
let's look i think more constructively
and i hope all of us can agree
let's look at what goes on on that u.s
mexico border because
the u.s is mexico's largest trading
partner
mexico is our largest trading partner
people
cost cross that border for commerce they
cost for jobs tourism and for
immigration it's the busiest border in
the world
so they're our neighbors they're our
business partners
and it's all long overdue i think you go
back to the eighties
the last time that we had some
significant immigration reform
and set rules for what goes on on the
busiest border in the world
including handling child migrants as
opposed to simply saying we're going to
separate them from their parents are
going to beat them up or something
or build a fictional wall i mean this is
all unbelievable
so i think for us on this show if we're
influencers
if we are voices i think all of us
across political lines need to say
to the congress stop the finger pointing
stop the blaming
get busy let's do something significant
for america and have immigration reform
that does something about
who crosses when they cross the dreamers
the influx let's do it
yeah we already had that one it was
called a wall and remain in mexico
policy
and no catch and release all right dana
tell me about the communications deal it
looks like
some of these biden flax are suffering
they're having a hard time
fielding questions even from the
mainstream media about this issue
um what's going on there it reminds me
of uh do you remember during the obama
years um
the right and fox news others would give
the obama administration a really hard
time because they would never say
radical islamic
uh terrorists they would they they would
just refuse to say it was like why won't
you say it
and then they just dug in it was like
the more you
ask them why don't they say it they're
not going to say it so i i think that
now we're in this situation
it doesn't matter you could get 500 000
migrant children they're not going to
say it's a crisis because
but you saw what jen saki said we're not
we don't have to meet your bar
for that okay but that's fine but people
have their own eyes and ears
and like to one's point like i also i
think about
you know the parents that tell their
teenage kids okay
this is where we drop you off you're on
your own god speed i mean that
that it's not that they're heartless
it's like they're heartbroken
and the other thing that we haven't
talked about is the fact that
you cannot get all the things that juan
wants without border security it's like
maslow's hierarchy of needs
you have to have security and then
everything else can get you to
enlightenment
and but in the meantime that base layer
is security and part of that is also
going to have to be
really dealing with the cartels and the
coyotes
you saw what happened yesterday when all
of those people were
25 people 27 people crammed into one suv
to try to get them into america
illegally they get hit by a semi-truck
several of them die others are like
wandering around in the desert there's
children there they don't have any
restraints
like that is not caring for the human
condition at all
but before we can that's why and that is
why you have to have
border security that will let you do all
of the other things like a temporary
worker program
visas dreamers things like that but
until you get that base layer
you are not going to be able to get
those things done in congress
yeah president trump katie did that he
threatened the mexican president to
designate
the drug cartels as foreign terrorist
organizations
if he didn't start cleaning up the surge
from the south and then the mexicans put
the army down
along their central american border and
a lot of those caravans stopped
biden comes in mexican army leaves and
now we have this
well and you have the new dhs secretary
saying basically
come right in but maybe wait for a
little while but the big scandal in the
news of the day
is the issue of the administration
releasing
100 coveted positive cases of people who
have come over over the border
who know knowingly got on buses to go to
different parts of the country
you had one woman in that foxnews.com
piece who said well i tested positive i
don't feel anything so i'm going to get
on a bus with my kid and go to north
carolina
where's dr fauci to talk about the
super spreader event of a hundred
positive people
knowingly and voluntarily moving on to
different parts of the country remember
all these
cdc graphics that they they produced the
one of the choir so there was one
there were 67 people and one person in
the choir who had coveted
and they spread it to six to eighty
seven percent of the people in that room
so if you add up the number of people
the 100 cases we know of
that's thousands of people who are going
to get this disease as a result
of the federal government not doing a
better job of making sure these people
are quarantined and the standards here
are insane
every state has different standards in
new york you have to quarantine for
14 days or whatever maybe it's changed
since then just for getting on a bus
just for traveling not even with a
positive covid test
and for the white house to sit today to
say well it's just a local
issue um they're the ones who are about
to send
every american a mask why aren't they
talking more about the idea
that they're letting these people in who
are covet positive
after we've just gone through this
pandemic it's absolutely insane
it's insane yeah you wouldn't do it at
an airport so you shouldn't be doing it
on foot across the southern border